Antonio was a wealthy merchant in the Italian city of Venice.
His friend, Bassanio, needed money to impress Portia, a wealthy heiress.
Antonio could not make the loan himself...
...because his own money was invested in a number of trade ships.
Antonio and Bassanio approached Shylock, a Jewish moneylender, for a loan.
In fact, Shylock disliked Antonio because he spoke out against his dishonest way of lending money.
To their surprise, Shylock agreed to lend Bassanio the money.
A condition, however, was that if the loan goes unpaid,...
...Shylock would be entitled to a pound of Antonio's flesh.
Antonio's ships were lost at sea, meaning that he was unable to repay the loan.
The matter went to court.
Shylock could indeed demand a pound of flesh from Antonio.
A legal expert, who was really Portia disguised as a man,...
...told Shylock that he could draw no blood.
The contract did not entitle him to any blood.
Consequently, Shylock got nothing.
He was found guilty of conspiring to kill a Venetian citizen.
The penalty was death, but all involved agreed that the punishment should be different.
Shylock was fined, and he had to convert to Christianity.
Soon after, the joyful news arrived that Antonio's ships came back safely.